[Music]
who's better than you
Saturday night you here with uncle Joey
final night to show sold out Thank You
church for [ __ ] letting these
[ __ ] know who's running things
now I understand beautiful day to be
alive in Denver
got up early a nice breakfast a little
bowl of green chilly little workout went
to the week store without a little
errand of law
you know remembers with the [ __ ] pot
heads that's it it all ends tonight back
to [ __ ] California we got the church
Monday we got the church Wednesday a guy
shows Friday night the I said forget
about it what about tonight tonight's
your big [ __ ] night
we're a couple Chiba Jews in my pocket
and I'm saying we got a big night for
that [ __ ] so I don't know what to
tell you I had a great [ __ ] time here
the club is great the [ __ ] food is
sensational I mean you know me though I
can [ __ ] take a [ __ ] little room
and turn it into a Taj Mahal
tremendously
I love smoking wreath with you
[ __ ] you gotta bring it when I
bring it and throw that matter if you
show up I'll give you the [ __ ] word
Bing and there you are like [ __ ]
animals that's why I love you
[ __ ] that's why tonight okay
okay
that's my poison for you [ __ ] oh
yeah you got some [ __ ] green on
it two different packaging in Denver in
Colorado they [ __ ] 70 milligrams I'm
going to dicta me but I fight like 22 of
them I'll be [ __ ] flying through the
air like mother Lee's Marvel Comics you
understand but I told you [ __ ]
I love smoking reefer
I don't care less about drink damage
jumping up and down I'm gonna say I
don't give a [ __ ] this is it taps into
the inner soul of my [ __ ] mind
you understand me
I'll just get the party started always
remember you can have a thousand
accolades but if you can't get the party
started go [ __ ] your mother all right
you might as well sit they eat ranch
dressing and hummus and shoot yourself
was refried Wharton County not a
Colorado to a sensation 28%
unfuckin real
[Music]
get down to the [ __ ] roach of life
you know I smoked a smoke break through
these things it's like a [ __ ] stick
of dynamite when I get my hands on but
never feel
I got another two or three of these
[ __ ] burning a hole in my
pocket that's what makes this unique
oh my god these [ __ ] roaches this is
the whole thing I missed the smoking
joints I don't lie to you I like smoking
my pop this is [ __ ] 9 it's quick it's
on my balcony but me I'm an old-school
[ __ ] bamboo type of [ __ ] you
know I'm saying then I graduated an easy
wine that now I'm doing the other one
with the [ __ ] do with the long hair
who the [ __ ] knows leave these [ __ ]
roaches that's how you become a [ __ ]
safecracker my smoking roaches and your
[ __ ] fingerprints disappear and there
you are
McDonald's robbing a [ __ ] safe
but that's it and that's that you know I
love your [ __ ] uncle Joey got
your back you know the same way you guys
got my [ __ ] back here we are by the
dumpster the story of my [ __ ] life
feels like that's why I belong [ __ ]
dumpster but I worked my way out of it
that's the most important BAM just like
that our two men with you [ __ ]
later you know I love you be safe if
you're going out tonight sit by the [ __ ]
and always watch the door and know how
to get the [ __ ] out of there you
understand me
and bring a little piece of you if you
have to you know uncle Joey we don't
give a [ __ ] we do what we do laws don't
apply to us you understand me I love you
cops up to stay black I'll be in touch
of you guys to maman and maybe later on